[Musik]
ich bin heute einfach mal vor und
wittler gegangen nach einem gewinn von
german and play einen link zu einer app
und die nachricht der junge ist 3 ich
hab da noch die blumen drauf gekriegt
und wer dann dafür eine app im app store
mit meinem logo und dem namen luca war
cool macht einfach eine app oder super
hammer
klasse aktion bei einer antwort auf
mahnung nachricht war dahin gehen sagen
wie tnf die neue app von congo after dem
modell also hat man das ganze eben
zusammen ich bin einfach in twitter
gegangen und man hat mit heftig wie
jemand gemacht hat für mich aber gar
nicht meine ff
was hältst du davon ja das ist genau
meine meinung aber ich wäre nicht klug
wenn ich die app nicht wenig mithelfen
würde diese app wurde gemacht von nethen
wir können noch keinen namen drauf
klicken und an wen er hat auch schon
eine app gemacht die bonner hde und der
handgemachte 39 euro ich bin vielleicht
ist die app ja cool hier für mich
gemacht hat also zecken wir die maus
dafür einfach dass die entweder für die
apple watch gemacht ist keine crazy luca
märkte die mitteilungen wenden kann so
gerne machen die app also high score 0
luca wir haben unten game center und
einmal ein
baldham bald kann man anscheinend sogar
sachen kaufen in der app cool
dann macht er da auch noch geld wird ist
da nicht nur negativ seien jetzt alles
also vielleicht ja cool also geschützt
und war direkt ins abenteuer ich denke
mal auf den lukas meili drauf und ihr
seht schon da eigentlich
was mach ich bin in der app die teile
dass das ist wow oder dagegen als falsch
es kann auch sein dass sich die roten
teile abwehren
ordner vaters gutmann
ich muss zugeben ich diesen arten von
dir gelesen habe und gesehen habe dass
bei jemandem unter meinem namen gemacht
hat dachte ich mir erst mal so
aber ich meine schaut ihr euch an das
mega geil ich meine tectura wenig
gedrückt halten könnte um die blauen
teil teurer werden wahrscheinlich auch
viel einfacher als er den ball an den
kopf
ich will bei 45 9 10 11 13 14 15 16 17
18 19
mein neuer halbgott 33 meine damen und
herren
[Musik]
video damit füllen einfach die bekannten
teilen schiefe und ich habe auch keine
lust wieder in die weiterführende neuen
freundes kolhoff muss ich zugeben
wirklich also in houston wenn du dieses
video werden sollte was sie denkt ich
den wird weil der main kanal kennt von
dieser app für mich gemacht hat meiner
meinung nach auf der schon sachen für
geld und mühe gemacht und sind das wird
doch alles einfach von runtergeladen
meine app motor schon mehrfach bewertet
und zwar megabörse
obwohl die leute wissen das ist gar
nicht von mir wie könnt ihr das meine
daten zusammengefasst dass ich meine app
aber sie ist cool deswegen will ich gar
nicht hätten hielten
ich hätte mal mit dir was machen
irgendwie
der ahnung
was
unter freunden mich denn ich hab keine
freunde das war heute von wieder meine
damen und herren können wir für diese
geile es vielleicht nicht ausgeblendet
da könnt ihr meinen kanal abonnieren und
hier unten findet ihr ein anderes video
eingeblendet auch mit seinem shop
eingeblendet irgendwo da könnt ihr
merchants kaufen und viele hatten mich
einander nachgefragt wann die website
wieder verfügbar sind ab anfang februar